what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the incumbent
advantage
and this is the idea that the person who
is already in power the incumbent has an
advantage in elections and in particular
we're going to focus on presidential
elections although this idea is pretty
common across different offices
now it turns out that if you go back
over roughly the last hundred years in
presidential elections that had an
incumbent that had a sitting president
running for a second term or maybe a
third or fourth term in the case of fdr
you have more than 80 percent of the
time it goes to the incumbent and this
right over here is a picture of the
presidential debates from c-span and
this is in 2012 between president barack
obama and mitt romney and president
obama of course was the incumbent and he
went on to win and once again not
unusual this happened 80 percent of the
time the last time that a challenger was
able to unseat an incumbent was in 1992
when you have president clinton was able
to beat president george h.w bush george
w bush's father george h
w bush and the time before and this is
26 years ago 26 years before the time of
the making of this video and to go even
before that the last time before 1992
would have been 1980 when reagan is able
to beat carter so this is a very unusual
thing for a challenger to be able to
beat an incumbent
now one thing i would like you to do is
pause this video think about why
incumbents might have such an advantage
okay so there's many scholarly papers
written about the idea of the incumbent
advantage both at the presidential level
and at other levels but we can come up
with some ideas as to why the incumbent
has the advantage
one is people already imagine that
individual as president because they are
the president
on top of that because they are already
president they've had many years of
being in the national spotlight and even
during the presidential campaign they
are still the president and so they have
that bully pulpit that president
roosevelt theodore roosevelt talked
about bully
pulpit
where they can get people's attention
when they want to even though the
challenger might be well-funded and the
press is definitely going to pay
attention to the challenger and give
them a lot of voice because the
president is the president they have the
state of the union address they can call
special sessions of congress they have
their regular press briefings and so
they have a much larger voice even
compared to a very prominent challenger
on top of that there might be some
notion of experience and this idea of
experience can go in many directions no
matter how which candidate has more life
experience which one is older
one could argue that no one has ever
really been the president unless they
are the president and so someone who has
been in that job for four years has been
able to build some experiences that
maybe they'll be able to build on for
their second term while the other person
might have to no matter what they've
done in the rest of their life being the
president is a fairly new experience
the other idea is that they are
experienced campaigners that they have
already run a successful presidential
campaign and this is their second time
around which could help winning that
campaign
another idea that might help an
incumbent and once again this is me
thinking about it i encourage you to
think about it and see if you buy these
or can come up with others is maybe
there's a sense of patriotism
that people are used to thinking of the
incumbent as their president for the
last several years and so they feel some
sense of loyalty to them this could even
be supercharged if maybe it's in wartime
or if the country is facing some type of
foreign policy crisis that they want to
stand behind the person during that time
of crisis they don't want to change
who's in charge in the middle of a war
or something like that
so i will leave you there these are just
some ideas why we see this phenomenon of
an incumbent advantage encourage you to
think about why this is happening